the book begins with a wonderful image
of you you know say this young man from
ELF of the castle and you're at the
Beverly Hills Hotel and you see this
helicopter oh yeah I would
what happened they said surely brought
me to Hollywood to do gambit but she
think she was doing over ran and I was a
week on my own in Hollywood
I was just I'd never been to America and
I was a wee comer and they put me at the
luxurious suite in the Beverly Hills
Hotel and then nobody ever talked to me
or photo B I didn't know anybody I was
just in this luxury hotel I'm ordering
caviar and champagne all on my own for a
week and in the daytime I used to go
down to the lobby and sit in the corner
see if I could see any stars yeah and
one day a helicopter landed and all the
flowers went up in the beds outside up
in the air and in wall John Wayne in a
complete cowboy hat just like that no I
think he was registering in the Beverly
Hills Hotel and he looked up and he saw
me in the corner and he said to me
what's your name kid I said Michael
Caine he said you in that movie Alfie I
said Jesse I saw that he said you're
gonna be a star kid I said oh thank you
sir and he said but let me give you some
advice he said talk low talk slow and
don't say - everything much and I had on
suede shoes and he said to me never
never wear suede shoes that's what he
said never wear suede shoes so I said
why he said because I just told you
you're gonna be a star kid he said and
you're gonna be in a gents toilet taking
a pee he said and the guy next to you is
gonna be taking a peek and he look and
he's gone Michael Caine
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we could and then they gonna pee all
over issue
[Applause]
[Music]
you